it's going to be left-hander shane
mcclanahan and interestingly enough he's
making his major league debut as far as
a regular season pitcher made his true
debut in the postseason last fall he's
ahead in the count
and the one-two he fires it by him at a
hundred and one how about that first
strikeout here
101 on the gun here
and a cut and a mess
well right back with it
and the fastball to canna at 101 and two
lethal sliders here
two-and-oh to count lowry the dh for
oakland today
to the right side foul
brasso
room for it makes the catch down near
the bullpen
area and it's a one two three first
ray's gonna be squaring off against
chris bassett scheduled to make his
sixth start of the season throwing the
ball well as of late 2-0 over the last
three starts
and that's a swing and a miss so
bottom of the first opens with the
strikeout
oh and now lau is hit by
that pitch it's tough to stay in command
of six different pitches
and a breaking ball and he gets the
strike out of a rosarina two strikeouts
in the first inning one ball two strikes
austin meadows tall left-handed batter
and he's been slumping
he breaks his bat lifts a fly ball right
center
biscotti closing that ball is going to
drop in between the two of them
the rays are going to get a run out of
this the throw comes through to the
plate but way late
laos scores and meadows winds up at
second and boy how that fell in between
the two of them it had a lot of hang
time
and wendell a line shot great play by
chapman on the backhand to end the
inning so that saved a run but the rays
do get won
wait for it
and strike three call
right there a hundred
the short stop position player that's a
strike call
strikeout number four he's faced
five hitters and has four strikeouts
and that hit down the third base line
fair
rose arena goes into a slide grabs it
and he'll flip it back in and moreland
has a two double
[Applause]
ground ball toward the middle and right
there is lau
tossed to first
no rounds ahead the man left bottom of
any two coming it's a pitch that no
one's looking for either you don't throw
it a lot and you don't throw it that
slow
and if you can oh there's a base head
breaking ball
extra bass is coming here
cannon's throat is not going to be in
time and mejia has himself
a double
breaking ball that stayed inside but
adamus
swung through it anyways
so that's three strikeouts for bassett
3-2 again and that is ball four a miss
inside
[Applause]
ooh look out up and in
and i think
kiermeier says it hit him
and adrian johnson agrees
and that one is lined towards center
lauriano coming in and he goes into a
slide and he makes the catch show the
race leave them loaded it's one nothing
tampa bay
balls hit hard in the center field the
base hit so it was a fast ball tony kemp
not impressed
and that's line to right and that's a
base hit phillips has it kemp's going to
try to score the throw to the plate is
there and he is out throw to second base
and can't escape so phillips comes up
throwing he made a nice throw and they
get camp at the plate brett phillips
playing through the baseball so a single
and he moves to second on the throw home
and now here's lorianno
that one is line fair
that will get a run home as kenneth
rounds third he'll come in to score
l'oreal with an rbi double and it's a
1-1 game
[Applause]
runner takes off and now a step off and
the throw to third and they're going to
get loriano
who is caught at third to end the inning
loriano
pulled something like that earlier in
this series and is out number three
right there one one time
that's a hot shot base hit into right
biscotti cutting to his left window's
going to dick for two
and he will make it
a double for joey wendell
and a high fastball of me he had chased
it so bassett gets out of the inning
couple of rays stranded we're through
three it's a one-one game
and a cut and a miss
and he's still not seeing him no he's
seen one today and that was at 100 on
the inside corner everything else has
been a breaker or a change up and that
was a nasty slider here to finish him
off so here's chapman chapman struck out
looking in the second inning
hit well the left field and
that baby's gone what a great feeling
that is for chapman who's been
struggling at the plate he turns around
mcclanahan and gives the a's a 2-1 lead
on his fourth home run of the year
adamus
swings and misses so the struggles
continue for
julia damas
3-2 pitch and he went around he's swung
at ball four
bass it'll take it he's got six
strikeouts including three in a row
raised down a run and just like they
have most of the time they've had some
chances they just cannot get the big hit
here's a long drive off the bat of lau
that ball
is way
out of here
brandon loud connecting to open the
bottom of the fifth inning a shot headed
toward right center field
and he got a hold of that one this game
is tied at two
here it is and that's taken ring him up
for rosa reyna knew it fastball on the
outside corner
and get right back to attack
and he throws a good curveball there to
get another strikeout that's number
eight
up the middle diving play kemp scott
gets up throws in time
terrific play by tony kemp
[Applause]
incredible play
hi fastball blew away
ninth strikeout for chris bassett he's
been very good again today
oh there's a strike and that takes care
of loriano
and that one not close so lowry will
take the walk two way better bring up
chapman who's struck out homer to bounce
to third
one pitches drilled right center field
hustling back and it's over the head of
phillips lowry's headed for third
they're gonna wave lowry home and he
will score the ace take the lead so
chapman finds the gap in right center
field to give the a's the lead
still alive
phillips aboard makes an aggressive turn
and will hang it first
so with two gone the rays gets
the base hit out of brett phillips and
with two out of the ninth the tiger run
in scoring position thinking about a
potential ball and dirt early break
three-two pitch
strike three called with a fast ball on
the outside corner so kiermeier gets
called out on strikes and the a's hang
on and win the final game of the road
trip and they get the split in this four
game series and boy what a series it was